hey youtubers is Charlie this week on
supernatural it is the dog's life is the
heal starts to take over Sam some guys
eaten cats and Dean is the dog whisperer
I've also got some really cool casting
news for season 9 let's talk about our
many favorite moments then I'll do my
review and talk about that casting news
first off the opening montage you can
always tell what kind of episode you're
gonna get on Supernatural from the
opening montage and this time it was a
laugh out loud Greatest Hits real then
there was another game of Thrones
reference I feel like the show owners
are trying to get one of the cast
members on Game of Thrones in like
season 5 or some future season would it
be hilarious to see Sam and Dean on Game
of Thrones what would they do and what
was our characters be somebody get on
that fan fiction right now stat next up
was Kevin's Casa de erotica moment that
was so great the funny thing here is is
that if you've ever been to Branson you
know that it is the opposite of erotic
the real fun didn't begin until Dean
drank those Scooby Snacks I feel like
the show owned this plot point so well
that I totally bought it it was
hilarious the pigeon moment was pushing
it just a little bit but overall Scooby
Dean was amazing in the most ridiculous
way possible the Top Chef mythology of
the story was actually really cool too
eating other things to take on their
powers but raise your hand if you
actually wondered what would happen if
he had eaten a piece of Sam I don't
think it totally would have worked that
way it's not like he would've gained
angel powers I think he only gets
organic abilities but I did like that
they actually did something with the
Ezekiel plot and this story
Dean is starting to get worried now that
Ezekiel's personality is going to take
over Sam's personality the ending was
also pretty nice too in the grand
tradition of silly supernatural episodes
obviously it was a very happy ending so
it was nice to see how those dogs get
adopted I'm a total sucker for dogs so
this was a bit of a slam dunk I saw it
coming a mile away but who does not love
to see dogs get adopted the real
question we had after this episode
though is how long is it going to be how
many more episodes before as the heel
just totally asserts himself over Sam
completely in previous episodes Dean's
always had to summon him but now in this
episode he basically just asserted
himself automatically there's still a
lot we don't know about what Ezekiel
wants exactly obviously he's trying to
do more than just heal himself
something's not quite right about that
guy but what did I think of this episode
overall I always loved silly
supernatural episodes like I said when a
show owns its silliness so well when it
doesn't take herself too seriously
it works so well and supernatural is
amazing at that obviously I always loved
Felicia
Charlie episodes the most but I write
this episode of b-plus just because it
was so much fun bonus points for use of
Game of Thrones I didn't like the vegan
characters too much I felt like they
were a little too silly I feel like they
could have created some other supporting
characters that didn't really need to be
silly at all
a Scooby Dean's storyline was strong
enough to carry all the jokes in the
episode but let me know what your
favorite moments were and what would you
do if you could talk to dogs or animals
for that matter I would probably just
talk to my dog about Game of Thrones I
bet he would be a huge fan of Jon Snow's
dire wolf so onto that casting news
supernatural just cast Timothy Omundson
from Psych to be Kane from the Cain and
Abel biblical duo on the show he's going
to be a retired trainer of Knights of
hell and you know how Abaddon is
basically trying to raise an army he's
going to come out of retirement so it's
gonna be a lot of fun next week though
Castiel is back be sure to subscribe to
get my video I'll be posting that next
Thursday after the episode airs as
always if you want to help me out please
like and share this video using the
tools below now click here to watch all
my other supernatural videos from this
season and you can click here to watch
all my American Horror Story videos
thank you so much for watching see you
guys tonight
high fives